yes welcome
Video F3
for minute
Game
recently
Inter
quick
play
nores very much like
typical symetrical
English
C another
idere C2
may the
C3 E35 something like keeping more
pieces on the
board
of
problemtic got
space
yes one idea exactly
that idea play Bishop
H3 mention
exch Drop  can
also Exchange play
E4 sorting let Ex Bishop G2
after
okay d k D7
C5 not
really helping black so
much
preparing5 R
B A4 further with K C5 or K
B6 I might want the Rook on B1 to play
B4 so yes I go K D5 now looks
like  like good
move gets rid of his Bishop probably and
also has got K
B6 as
threat
i don't think after Bishop B2 I can play
K B6 instantly because Queen d8es a he
drops back the bishop and takes
later wow
what
F5 K C7 just winning
exchange
d
ideaigen
also play
first may
Tempo Queen D7
C6
Prev
yes play Queen
D4
exch7 end winning exchange and having
queens
queensquare queen6
got
c77 let
quickly
Check looking very
far misplace the
R now maybe just first
check and now
centraliz A4 B4 and got K D5
coming nicely Controlling this
position really now Bishop doesn't have
any
square
D si
weeks really strange
move maybe maybe play simple intending
Queen
H4 not badly position on F6
anyway
yes I don't know G4
G4 Queen H4 win
Bishop so far
yes queen7 take play  King King F2
something yes come on keep it simple King
G3
just
G5
Prob take
play4
better
Moves keep under
controlang
take
here want R takes F5 exactly so
that
easier
just
exactly
the go
F5
R R
v
promote
UPS
yes e seconds
okay yes
yes
structure structure
not
blackib
B
blockable
thanks